The National Health Service would be
marvelous if they were not political
interference so everybody knows the
problem and they all send know what the
solution is.
The solution is decentralization,
give power back to the hospitals and the
doctors because the secret of the NHS,
very curious secret is that it isn't
entirely perverse structure.
You'll see it's set up as a hierarchical
organization of bureaucracy such that
the wisdom at the top filters down
through the instruments in the middle to
achieve the effect you want to achieve
at the bottom.
Armies are perfect examples of that and
that's what Britain did during the war.
It's were of course the way in which
armies are organized.
It's the way in which governments are
organized.
The point about armies is that they are
run by generals and the generals have
the brains and the experience to know
what they are doing.
So an army is a perfect example of an
organism in which the brains are at the
top and filter through to the actions
down below if the general is there any
good.
The National Health Service is the most
peculiar structure in which the brains
are at the bottom.
That is,
say at the top,
you have amateurs,
politicians,
uh,
determining these things.
And at the bottom,
or at least near the bottom,
you have the doctors and the nurses and
the technicians who actually know
something about what is necessary to
solve the problems.